This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. Why do some women yearn for Shakira's black hair to make a comeback? And whatever happened to the power couple of my dreams, Mariah Carey and Luis Miguel, I'm Maria Garcia. You may remember me from my podcast, Anything for Selena, or My Thivo. And now I'm back to unpack more stories from the present and the past. Listen to Mui excited with Maria Garcia on the IHeart Radio app,
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客，保证由真人出演。为什么有些女性渴望夏奇拉的黑发卷土重来？我梦想中的权力夫妻玛丽亚·凯莉和路易斯·米格尔又怎么了？我是玛丽亚·加西亚。你可能还记得我的播客《为赛лена付出一切》（Anything for Selena）或《My Thivo》。现在我回来了，要和大家一起探讨更多过去和现在的故事。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听玛丽亚·加西亚带来的《Mui excited》，
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Where's my phone? Juliana, maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, because I have questions. And I bet you do too. Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms?
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。比尔，为什么我的眼皮一直在跳？这是否意味着我正处于围绝经期？我的手机呢？朱莉安娜，也许我们可以问问真正的真人。是的，因为我有很多疑问。我敢打赌你也是。比如，分房睡正常吗？
We do that. And I still need to know why my poop's been green. We've got actual people answering these exact questions. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your. podcast. I'm Munga Shatikula and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive.
我们就是这样。而且我还是想知道为什么我的便便是绿色的。我们有专业人士来解答这些具体的问题。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何平台上收听《比尔和朱莉安娜播客》。我是姆加·沙蒂库拉，我带着我的播客《天际线大道》的新一季回来了。
This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, kermudgins, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live forever on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Betrayal Weekly is back with brand new stories from threatening text messages disturbing a small Midwestern town.
这一次，我采访了科学家、生物朋克、怪脾气的人、布鲁斯音乐厂牌老板、超级老年人和果阿顶级的冷冻疗法实验室，试图理解这种长生不老的痴迷，以及它对我们所有人的意义。在这一过程中我也惹上了一些麻烦。我想大概可以从骨骼重塑开始吧。这没用。让它看起来更有轮廓感。他们说有用。我也不知道。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何平台上收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》。《背叛周刊》（Betrayal Weekly）携全新故事回归，从威胁短信扰乱中西部一个小镇开始。
It was from an unknown number. Who else is getting these messages? Why did it start with us? To long cons and stolen identities. Who lies about being this sick? This was the last time I ever believed a word she said. Listen to Betrayal Weekly on the Iheartedly. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
那是来自一个陌生号码的。还有谁在收到这些消息？为什么是从我们开始的？到漫长的骗局和被盗的身份。谁会谎称自己病得这么重？这是我最后一次相信她说的任何一个字。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《背叛周刊》。
This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. This episode is a rerun. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the
我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》（the I Am Rapaport Stereo podcast）与你听过的任何人都不一样。如果你正在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何其他吸引我注意的事情的强烈观点，那么现在就订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子绝对、百分之百应该因为饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我是拉帕波特》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十岁最大的变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。本期节目是重播。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到
podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, to just jump straight to the chase, we are talking about perhaps one of the most defining parts of our 20s, the overwhelming uncertainty of just being in this decade. If this decade had one word to describe it, one thing, to trump them all, it would be uncertainty. We are lost in this very weird haze of not really knowing who we are, not really knowing what the future holds, what's going to happen with our jobs, with our friends, with our finances, with our love lives. And even once you think you have some part of it figured out, another part of your life suddenly crumbles. And you're kind of
播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析你的二十岁心理学。今天，为了直奔主题，我们来谈谈二十岁最具有决定性的部分之一，即仅仅处于这个十年所带来的巨大不确定性。如果这个十年可以用一个词来形容，那就是压倒一切的不确定性——不确定性。我们迷失在一种非常奇怪的迷雾中，不太清楚自己是谁，不太清楚未来会怎样，我们的工作、朋友、财务和爱情生活会发生什么。即使你认为你已经把生活的一部分搞清楚了，你生活中的另一部分也会突然崩塌。而你
just left feeling as lost as you were before. So I got this DM from a list. the other day that I wanted to share, which really inspired me to talk about this, because going back through the archives, I realized we have never sat down and done a full episode dedicated to this feeling, despite it being, I would say, universal. This is what her DM said. Hi, Gemma. I'm in my 20s, like I'm sure most of your listeners are, so there must be others who relate to this feeling. My dilemma is that everyone tells me to just try something, and that it doesn't matter what path I'm taking in my 20s as long as I'm moving forward. What really paralyzes me, though, is not knowing whether the path I choose to take will make me
最终只会感到和以前一样迷茫。所以前几天我从一个听众那里收到了这样的私信，我想分享一下，这真的很启发我去谈论这个话题，因为在翻阅过往档案时，我意识到我们从来没有坐下来做过一期专门探讨这种感觉的节目，尽管我想说这是一种普遍现象。她的私信是这样写的。嗨，杰玛。我和你的大多数听众一样正处于二十多岁，所以肯定还有其他人能对这种感觉产生共鸣。我的困境是，每个人都告诉我只管去尝试，只要我在前进，在二十多岁时走哪条路并不重要。然而，真正让我瘫痪的是，我不知道我选择的道路是否会让我
happy or at least happier than any other path. When I visualize my future, it just feels like a big, ominous gray cloud, and I can't help but feel like if I just knew one part of the story, I could decide once and for all what direction to take. How do I deal with my fear of uncertainty? it's the biggest thing holding me back. I just knew like instantly upon reading this how many of us, and I can include myself in this group, can relate to that feeling.
感到幸福，或者至少比任何其他道路更幸福。当我设想我的未来时，它感觉就像一朵巨大、不祥的乌云，我不禁觉得，如果我能知道故事的一部分，我就可以一劳永逸地决定朝哪个方向走了。我该如何应对我对不确定性的恐惧？这是阻碍我前进的最大因素。我几乎在阅读这封信的瞬间就知道，我们中有多少人——我也把自己包括在这个群体中——能对这种感觉产生共鸣。
The feeling that our futures are not necessarily exciting, but actually really scary and really ominous. And a lot of that fear of the unknown really fuels indecision. And it fuels not making decisions that are important to make at this stage in our life, which of course fuels later dissatisfaction. But I think when you understand why we feel such uncertainty to begin with, why it is human nature to turn away from the unknown, but also how we can shift our feelings about uncertainty so that it feels less scary. That is when this sensation has less control of you. You know, you're no longer fighting a losing battle against it. Uncertainty can become perhaps your sign that you're going in the right direction. It can be a sign of growth. It can be a sign that you are trying new things and you're expanding as a person. So you welcome it.
那种认为我们的未来不一定是令人兴奋的，但实际上非常可怕和不祥的感觉。许多对未知的恐惧实际上助长了优柔寡断。它促使我们在人生的这个阶段不做那些需要做出的重要决定，这当然会导致日后的不满。但我认为，当你了解为什么我们一开始会感到如此不确定，为什么转头背离未知是人类的天性，以及我们如何能够转变对不确定性的感觉，让它觉得不那么可怕时。这就是这种感觉对你失去控制的时候。你知道，你不再与它进行一场注定失败的战斗。不确定性或许可以成为你走在正确方向上的信号。它可以是成长的信号。它可以是一个信号，表明你正在尝试新事物，并且作为一个人正在扩展。所以你欢迎它。
You welcome the sensation rather than running away from it. If that sounds kind of implausible and out of reach, let me explain how exactly we can get to that point. If you want to get to that place, we're going to have to make uncertainty feel like an asset. And we need to have a better strategy for coping with this feeling. And so that is exactly what we're going to. are going to talk about today, how we can celebrate rather than fear the unknown, how we can integrate this feeling into our life plan, see it as a sign, but also some of the origins of why we feel this way, not just in our 20s, but as a species. All of that and more and so much
你欢迎这种感觉，而不是逃跑。如果这听起来有些不可信且遥不可及，让我解释一下我们如何才能准确地达到那个点。如果你想到达那个地方，我们必须让不确定性感觉像是一种资产。我们需要有更好的策略来应对这种感觉。这正是我们今天要讨论的内容，我们如何庆祝而不是害怕未知，我们如何将这种感觉融入我们的人生规划中，将其视为一个标志，以及我们为什么会有这种感觉的一些起源，不仅在我们的二十多岁，而且作为整个人类物种。所有这些以及更多的心理学知识，所以请继续收听。你已经听过了混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接开始吗？在免费的IHare Radio应用程序中，从头到尾观看所有你最喜欢的播客。制造点动静。呜呼！在诸如《Bestie Listen》、《Hey Jonas》和《Los Culturistas》等节目中捕捉每一次笑声和白眼。现在有了完整视频。我就把这个放在这里。还是熟悉的搭档，还是熟悉的默契，所有你一直错过的爆笑时刻就在你的屏幕上。
psychology, so stay with us. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHare Radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas and Los Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen.
打开免费的I-Hard Radio应用程序。搜索视频播客并点击观看。比尔，为什么我的眼皮一直在跳？这是否意味着我正处于围绝经期？也许我患有成人多动症。我需要查一下。我的手机呢？朱莉安娜，你的手机发烫了。
Open the free I-Hard Radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Maybe I have adult ADHD. I need to look this up. Where's my phone? Julianna, your phone is hot to the touch.
我想它是在请求你休息一下。你知道吗？也许我应该直接问ChatGPT。或者我们可以问一个真正的真人。是的，比如伴侣性治疗师。哇，这升级得真快，不过好吧。因为我有疑问。我们有疑问。我敢打赌每个人都有疑问。
I think it's asking you for a break. You know what? Maybe I should just ask chat GPT. Or maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, like a couple sex therapist. Whoa, that escalated quickly, but okay. Because I have questions. We have questions. And I bet everyone has questions.
比如，分房睡正常吗？我们就是这样。那这个呢？贿赂孩子是不良育养还是只是谈判？哦，我还是想知道为什么我那次便便是绿色的？纯属假设，对吧？好吧，与其让互联网瞎猜，我们有真人来回答这些具体的问题。和我们一起笑，肯定比在网络上花三个小时钻牛角尖要好。请收听《比尔和朱莉安娜播客》。在Iheart
Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms? We do that. How about this one? Is bribing your kids bad parenting or just negotiating? Oh, and I still do need to know why was my poop green that one time? hypothetically, right? Okay, well, instead of letting the internet guess, we've got actual people answering these exact questions. And laughing with us has got to be better than spending three hours down a rabbit hole online. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. On the Iheart
radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方。嘿，大家好，我是保尔·韦尔齐，我想和大家聊聊保尔的最佳播客。威尔·法瑞尔的大钱玩家网络与IHart Radio。我每周都会和一位特邀嘉宾坐在一起，我们讨论
radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your podcasts. Hey, guys, Paul Verzi here, and I want to talk to you about Paul's best podcast. Will Ferrell's Big Money Players Network and IHart Radio. I sit down each week with a special guest, and we discusses. the absolute best of things. It's that, and then there's everything else. He would just shout one line, and it would murder. Marie, lunch! No, burn.
绝对最棒的事情。就是这样，然后还有其他所有事情。他会直接喊出一句台词，然后全场爆笑。玛丽，午餐！不，太逊了。让我们聊聊我们在路上经历过的最棒的时刻。我想要一杯鸡尾酒。老兄，乔竟然能买到西南航空航班上最后一排中间座位的机票。乔，我就是你的航班。太棒了。宾夕法尼亚州立大学的人在球场上走动，球员以为乔是他的前教练。他拥抱了他，而且抱得很紧，
Let's talk about the best moments that we had on the road. I would love a cocktail. Dude, Joe could get last row, middle scene on a Southwest Airlines flight. Joe, I was your flight. It was great. The guy on Penn State moving on the field, and the player thought Joe is his former coach. And he hugged him, and he hugged him,
而乔就顺势配合了。那个人说，教练，你在这里干什么？教练，乔直接说，伙计。当你走进去时，那真是疯狂。我的意思是，这是一场视觉盛宴。当时我想，这也不是我的菜，但我们已经在这儿了。入乡随俗吧？顶级运动员、厨师、音乐家，每个人。
and Joe just went with it. And the guy goes, what are you doing here, coach? Coach and Joe just goes, man. And you walk in, and it is bananas. I mean, it's a feast for the eyes. And I was like, it's not my thing either, but we're here. When in Rome? Top athletes, chefs, musicians, everybody.
请在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听保尔的最佳播客。2015年，十几岁的女孩乔伊·摩根发现了一个来自宗教团体“基督里的以色列联合会”（简称IU.I）的奇怪而引人注目的YouTube布道视频。她最初的好奇心逐渐演变成了狂热的信仰。她与朋友和家人疏远，拥抱了新的身份，全身心投入到IUIC中，并相信自己找到了真理。IUIC是我有生以来最好的家庭。事实上，她找到了许多人所说的邪教。而在2018年的节礼日，乔伊永远地消失了。
Listen to Paul's best podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2015, teenager Joy Morgan discovered strangely compelling YouTube sermons from the religious group, Israel United in Christ, or IU.I. Her initial curiosity developed into devotion. She distanced herself from friends and family, embraced new identity, immersed herself in the IUIC, and believed she'd found the truth. IUIC is the best family that I've ever had. In fact, she had found what many called a cult. And on Boxing Day 2018, Joy disappeared forever.
在全新的六集调查播客《失踪的姐姐》中，查理·布林克赫斯特-卡夫和弗雷·特恩探讨了乔伊的故事、她留下的家庭以及她发现的宗教团体。你知道当你获得那种自由时，我不想留在这里。我想离开。我现在想继续。这是一个关于谎言、真相、一个渴望归属感的年轻女性，以及一个仍在等待答案的家庭的故事。
In the new six-part investigative podcast, The Missing Sister, Charlie Brinkhurst Cuff and Freiturn explore Joy's story, the family she left and the religious group she found. You know when you get that a freedom, I don't want to be here. I want to get out. I want to go ahead now. It's a story about truth, lies, a young woman yearning to belong, and a family still waiting for answers.
所有剧集现已全部上线，可供一口气听完。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《失踪的姐姐》。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。这个季度，我们请来了一些很棒的嘉宾来提供建议。像蒂凡尼·哈迪什这样的嘉宾。有点滑进人们的私信里。我喜欢Bumble。还有，女孩，
All episodes available now to binge. Listen to The Missing Sister on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. This season, we've got some awesome guests ready to dole out advice. guests like Tiffany Haddish. Kind of slide into people's DMs. I like Bumble. Also, girl,
Farmers Only.com。旧货甩卖、葬礼、拍卖通常都不错。那里有很多好男人。健身房附近的杂货店。达西·卡丁。我记得当时觉得，我知道这是一个好建议，但我真的不想那样做。
Farmers Only.com. At state sales, funerals, auctions are usually good. There's a lot of good men there. Grocery stores near gyms. Darcy Cardin. I remember being like, I know this is good advice, but like I really don't want to do that.
所以你没有听从她的建议？我没有听从她的建议。你现在还和那个女人是朋友吗？不是。她实际上有点有毒。尼尔·德rasse·泰森。我一辈子都在仰望星空。我是一个极客小孩。
So you didn't take her advice? I didn't take her advice. Are you still friends with that woman? No. She actually was kind of toxic. Neil degrass Tyson. I spent my whole life looking up. I was a geek kid.
我12岁时就有一个望远镜。所以你很长时间没有做爱了。雪莉·奥特里。你是个肥皂剧迷吗？《年轻的骚动》。好吧。首先，你应该知道那是《年轻与骚动不安的人》。
I had a telescope at age 12. So you didn't have sex for a long time. Sherry O'Terry. Were you a soap opera person? Young and restless. Okay. Well, first of all, you should know it's the young and the restless.
我简直不敢相信你把名字念错了。我们中的一些人将其缩写，因为我们这么多年来一直表现得很奇怪。T.S.麦迪逊。你喜欢波利（多边恋）吗？不，不。我不这么认为。不。我本来可以对那个说不的。
I can't even believe you're mispronouncing the title. Some of us abbreviated because we've been so weird for so many years. T.S. Madison. Are you into Polly? No, no. I don't think so. No. I could have told you no on that.
女孩，你为什么不喜欢波利？仅仅根据。她的穿着和发型来看。她不是个波利。她不是个波利。安娜·法瑞斯、戴夫·弗兰科、玛德琳·克莱因、汉娜·盖兹比、亚当·斯科特、旺达·赛克斯等等。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《亲爱的切尔西》。我对不确定性的恐惧，我想，绝对是在我意识到
Girl, why do not into Polly? Just based on. what she's wearing and the way her hair is styled. She was not in a polly. She's not in a polly. Anna Ferris, Dave Franco, Madeline Klein, Hannah Gadsby, Adam Scott, Wanda Sykes, and more. Listen to Dear Chelsea on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My fear of uncertainty, I think, definitely shifted when I realized that
不确定性是无聊和可预测的反义词时发生了转变。如果我知道，我的生活到底会变成什么样，如果我知道每个拐角后面是什么，我将遇到的每一个朋友的名字，直到我退休前的整个履历。是的，我会觉得不那么不确定。但活着的意义又在哪里呢？我认为生活的新鲜感、经历、惊喜，在某种意义上才是让这一切变得值得的原因。你不可能拥有惊喜。
uncertainty is the opposite of boredom and predictability. If I knew, exactly how my life was going to turn out if I knew what was around every single corner, the name of every single friend I would meet, my entire resume until the time I retire. Yes, I would feel less uncertain. But what would the point of being alive even be? I think the newness of life, the experiences, the surprises, they are really what makes this whole thing worthwhile in a sense. You can't have surprises.
没有不确定性，你就无法拥有意想不到的快乐，无法学习，无法拥有兴奋和期待。它是许多原本非常美妙和令人愉快的体验的核心成分。这就是我个人在经历那些因未知而感到瘫痪的自然时刻时，正在学会欣赏和关注的重点。我这里有点操之过急了。是的，不确定性可能有其好处。
You can't have unexpected joy. You can't learn. you can't have excitement and anticipation without uncertainty. It is a core ingredient in so many otherwise really amazing and pleasurable experiences. And that's what I'm personally learning to appreciate and focus on when I do have those very natural moments of being paralyzed by all that I don't know yet. I'm kind of jumping the gun here. Yes, uncertainty may have its upsides.
我们绝对可以换个角度看待它，但我们为什么一开始就会经历它，又是什么让它如此令人抓狂地不舒服？这才是我们首先需要确定的。就像我在开始时所说的那样，二十岁的不确定性出于各种原因基本上是一对孪生兄弟。首先，我希望你能对自己宽容一点。你基本上是第一次在做所有事情。你基本上是一个成年幼儿或成年儿童，是的，希望你能阅读，能写作，希望你已经学会了如厕训练以及所有这些事情，
We definitely can think about it differently. but why do we even experience it to begin with and what makes it so freaking uncomfortable? That's really what we have to nail down first. Like I said in the beginning, uncertainty in our 20s are basically two peas in a pod for a variety of reasons. Firstly, I want you to give yourself some grace. You are doing everything for the first time ever, basically. You are basically an adult toddler or an adult child who, yes, can read, hopefully and can write and is hopefully potty train and all those things,
但你现在正在经历更高层次的情境，更高层次的学习体验，这些体验在情感上很复杂，并不简单。在经历这些的同时，你也没有了年轻时所依赖的安全网。你失去了老师、学校系统和社会系统所提供的保证和安全感，而这个社会系统希望你不会掉进裂缝中。你只能靠自己。因此，不确定性让人感到更加惊慌，因为你觉得自己是那个将要承担负担、经历
but you are now experiencing the next level of situations, the next level of learning experiences that are emotionally complex and not straightforward. And as you're experiencing that, you also are without the same safety net that you relied upon when you were younger. And you're without the reassurance and the security of teachers and parents and a school system and a societal system that hopefully isn't going to, you fall through the cracks. You're on your own. And uncertainty, therefore, feels a lot more alarming because you feel like you're the one who is going to hold the burden, experience
任何糟糕决定或任何糟糕结果的全部负担的人。在这个时候，一切都压在你身上。这其中的另一个因素是，因为你是一个成年幼儿，你还没有足够的生活经验来知道事情最终会为你解决。即使它们第一次没有解决，即使它们现在没有解决。四五十岁及以后的人知道分手不是世界末日，因为他们经历过并在此之前生存下来。他们知道犯重大错误、失去朋友或失去工作并不是世界末日，因为他们有以前的生活经验作为证据来告诉他们这一点。
the full burden of any poor decision or any poor outcome you made. It's all on you at this point. Another element of this is that because you are an adult toddler, you haven't had enough life experience yet to know that things will eventually work out for you. even if they don't the first time, even if they are not working out right now. People in their 40 years and their 50 years and later, they know that the breakup isn't the end of the world because they've experienced them and survived before. They know making a major mistake or losing a friend or losing a job isn't the end of the world because they have evidence from previous life experience to tell them that.
但是你，你没有那些相同的数据点。你没有那些相同的例子目录来告诉你一切都会好起来的。对于你来说，对于我们许多二十多岁的人来说，不确定性并没有像年长的人那样有一个结局。然后，当然，为了火上浇油，还有一个事实，那就是你有点生活在里程碑之间。这个十年绝对是一个永恒过渡的十年。你知道，你不再是一个青少年，但是，你知道，你还真的不觉得自己是一个成年人。你没有达到那个财务水平。你在职业生涯中还没有安定下来。
But you, you don't have those same data points. You don't have that same catalogue of examples that tell you everything is going to be okay. Uncertainty for you and uncertainty for a lot of us in our 20s doesn't have a conclusion the way that it has for people who are older. Then, of course, just to add even more fuel to the fire, there's the fact that you're kind of living between milestones. And this decade is definitely one of perpetual transition. You know, you're no longer a teenager, but, you know, you don't really feel like an adult yet. You're not at that financial level. You're not settled in a career.
你没有像你期望成年人那样在一个关系中安定下来。你到底是什么？这就是心理学家所说的阈限空间，也就是中间地带。而阈限的情感空间，就其本质和定义而言，会让人迷失方向，因为它们没有附带明确的剧本。当然，也没有准确的方法。而且没有人能够告诉你，比如，好吧，你做得很好。你做得很好。你很成功。在生命的早期，这是我一直在和
You're not settled in a relationship, the way that you expect adults to be. What are you really? It's what psychologists call a liminal space, the in-between. And liminal emotional spaces are, by nature, by definition, disorientating because they don't come with a clear script. And, of course, there's no accurate way. and there's no one who's going to be able to tell you, like, okay, you're doing, you're doing well. You're doing fine. You are being, you are successful. Earlier in life, this is something I talk to
人们谈论的事情。在生命的早期，你的整个日子、星期、月份都是建立在一个结构中的，这个结构会告诉你你是否做得很好。生活表现有明确的基准。比如成绩，比如升到下一个年级，比如一大群处于相同情况、同时期、与你同龄的人，你可以用他们来对照你的进度。而且他们可能都在同一个环境中，比如在学校里。你不再有那个了。你没有那个相同的框架来环顾四周，思考，好吧，我做得很好，或者我做得不好。这些是我可以改进的领域，或者这些是我表现出色的领域。你不再有那个了。这可能看起来很武断，但那些社会结构和
people about all the time. Earlier in life, your entire days, weeks, months are set up in a structure that will tell you if you are doing well. There are clear benchmarks for life performance. Things like grades, things like passing to the next year level, things like a whole cohort of people in the same situation at the same time and the same age as you with whom you can mark your progress against. And they're probably all in the same environment like at school. You don't have that anymore. You don't have that same framework to look around and think, okay, I'm doing okay or I'm not doing okay. And these are the areas I can improve or these are the areas that I'm excelling. You don't have that anymore. And it might seem really arbitrary, but those social structures and those
环境结构，以及那种背景实际上提供了大量的平静感和稳定感。所以在这个十年里，你几乎突然失去了很多以前让你保持脚踏实地、安全、结构和方向的东西。当然，最后，可能感觉像是一个诅咒，但绝对不是，那就是作为一个世代，我们拥有比以往更多的选择。我们确实有。这是一件美好的事情，每个人都告诉我们我们非常特权。我们也知道这产生了一个真正的选择悖论，可能会让人感到相当窒息。你知道，令人惊奇的是，当我们二十多岁的时候，大约80%的门向我们敞开。当然，有些事情我们可能再也做不到了。不幸的是，如果你从小就没有训练过，你可能不会成为一名
environmental structures, and that context actually provides a great deal of, and a great sense of calm and stability. So you have, during this decade, almost suddenly lost a lot of what previously allowed to just stay grounded. Security, structure, direction. And of course, finally, what may feel like a curse, but certainly isn't, is the fact that as a generation we have more choices than ever. We really do. And it's a beautiful thing and everyone tells us we're very privileged. We also know that that creates a real paradox of choice that can be quite stifling. You know, it is amazing that when we're in our 20s, like 80% of the doors are open to us. Definitely there are some things that we probably can't do anymore. You know, unfortunately, you're probably not going to become an
奥运体操运动员。但总的来说，你知道，你几乎在所有其他事情的起跑线上。所有的门都是敞开的。你知道这到底有多可怕吗？你可能知道，因为你正在经历它，但随着你做的每一个决定，你似乎关上的门就越多，而对于你以后是否真的想重新穿过那扇门，却没有任何确定性。对于接下来会发生什么也没有任何确定性。关闭那些门似乎比实现它要可怕得多。所以你什么也不做。你被选择和无休止的优柔寡断的利弊清单所麻痹，我们称之为决策瘫痪。这确实是二十岁不确定性的解释。对于为什么不确定性在任何情况下——不仅仅是关于我们二十岁时的重大事项——对我们作为物种来说如此不舒服，还有一个更为人性的解释。
Olympic gymnast if you haven't been training since you were a trial. But in general, you know, you're at the start line of pretty much everything else. All the doors are open. Do you know how utterly terrifying that actually is? You probably do because you're experiencing it, but it certainly does feel like with each decision you make, the more doors you seem to close with no certainty around whether you might actually want to go back through that door later. And no certainty around what might happen next. Closing those doors seems a lot more scary than it does fulfilling. So you do nothing. You're paralyzed by choice and the endless pro-cons list that we know as decision paralysis. That's really the 20-something explanation for uncertainty. There's also a more human explanation as
首先非常显而易见的一点是，我们的大脑天生就会寻求稳定和清晰，因为当某事是已知和熟悉的时候，危险和威胁的机会自然就会减少。现在，控制这种原始冲动的我们大脑的一部分，实际上有两个特定区域。它是前额叶皮层，也就是正前方这里，以及边缘系统，它位于我们大脑的深处。这是我们所谓的旧大脑的一部分。在2000年代初做的一系列研究
to why uncertainty in any capacity, not just when it comes to the big ticket items of our 20s, is so uncomfortable for us as a species. To firstly really state the obvious, our brains, they are wired to seek out stability and clarity because when something is known and familiar, there are, of course, less opportunities for danger and threats. Now, the part of our brain that controls this primal urge, there's two specific regions, actually. It's the prefrontal cortex, so right up here at the front, and the limbic system, which is really deep inside our brain. It's part of what we call the old brain. A series of studies done in the early
基本上发现，当我们暴露在模棱两可的事物中时，比如一张模棱两可的图像或模棱两可的风景，边缘系统，特别是杏仁核，会被点亮。即使这些参与者在一个没有直接危险的实验室环境中，你的大脑也总是会对它不理解的事物做出过度谨慎和过分热心的反应，比如未来的未知。但这种感觉也是我们无法压抑的。它是自动的。而且有充分的理由，你知道，我们希望我们评估危险的那一部分不依赖于我们的判断，并且能够快速采取行动。你知道，我们对不确定性如此反感，主要是根源于我们需要它，并且
2000s basically found that when we are exposed to ambiguous things like an ambiguous image or ambiguous scenery, the limbic system, particularly the amygdala, light up. Even when these participants were in a laboratory setting where there is no immediate danger, your brain is always going to respond overcautiously and overzealously to something it doesn't understand, such as the unknowns of the future. But that feeling is also something that we can't suppress. It's automatic. And for good reason, you know, we want that part of us that assesses danger to not be reliant on our judgment and to be able to act quick. And, you know, the reason that we have such an aversion to uncertainty is primarily rooted in the fact that we needed to and
为了生存。当你面对未知时，你知道，你的大脑会立即寻找尽可能多的信息，真实的或想象的来填补空白。我们的大脑天生就会这样做。你可能通过另一个词知道这一点，那就是灾难化。你的大脑正试图弄清楚这里可能发生的所有事情是什么。它将模拟结果。它将生成预测。问题是，它实际上根本不知道会发生什么。所以它提供所有这些情况，其中一些完全不可能，其中一些可能更有可能。我们并不总是能辨别或区分什么更有可能，什么更不可能。我们只是在接收来自大脑这个非常古老的部分的信息。
order to survive. When you face an unknown, you know, your brain will immediately seek out as much information as it can, real or imagined to fill the gaps. Our brain is wired to do this. You might know this by another term, which is catastrophizing. Your brain is trying to figure out what's every possible thing that's going to happen here. It's going to simulate outcomes. It's going to generate predictions. The problem is, it actually has no idea what's going to happen. So it's serves up all these situations, some of them completely impossible, some of them may be more likely. We can't always discern or tell the difference between what is more likely and what is less likely. We are just receiving information from this very old, ancient part of our brain.
我们随着它的到来而体验它。我们在所有的恐惧来临的时候体验它，却无法打断它并说，等等，我为什么要这样想？我怎么知道这会发生。哦，等等，我其实并不知道。所以这把我带到了下一个点。我们的许多焦虑和恐惧实际上并不一定源于某些事情在现实中出了错，而是源于“如果……会怎样”的问题，如果发生这种情况会怎样，如果发生更糟糕的事情会怎样。如果最坏的情况发生会怎样？这是因为我们的大脑会一直处于这种循环中，为我们提供潜在的结果，直到它有了某种解决方案或闭环。它不想关闭警报系统，直到给警报的原因赋予了意义或者识别出了问题所在。
And we're experiencing it as it comes. We're experiencing all the fear as it comes without being able to interrupt that and say, wait, how do I, why do I think this? How do I know this is going to happen. Oh, wait, I actually don't. So this brings me to a next point. A lot of our anxiety and our fears don't actually emerge from necessarily something having gone wrong in actuality, but from the question of what if, what if this happens, what if this even worse thing happens? What if the worst thing happens? This is because our brain will stay in this loop of providing us with potential outcomes until it has some kind of resolution or closure. It doesn't want to switch off the alarm system until the reason for the alarm has been given meaning or it's identified what the problem was.
就像我说的，过去这很有用，现在它只是彻头彻尾的烦人。这很烦人。而不确定性本该就是这种感觉。它本该让人感到烦恼、糟糕和沮丧，因为同样，它想让你保持警惕。它想抓住你的注意力。就像一个巨大的闪亮广告牌或一个巨大的红色停止标志，它希望你直视它。它希望你进行引导。它的焦点集中在你所不理解和不确定的事情上，以便你可以为它提供一种闭环感。问题是，如果你给你的焦虑和对未知的恐惧一个答案，如果你给自己一个不确定的理由，更具体地说，你给它一个目的。它其实就会消失。
And like I said, in the past that was useful, now it's just plain old annoying. It's annoying. And your uncertainty is meant to feel that way. It's meant to feel annoying and awful and frustrating because, again, it wants to keep you alert. It wants to grab your attention. like a big shiny billboard or a big red stop sign, it wants you to be looking straight at it. It wants you to be directing. It's focused onto the thing you don't understand and that you're unsure about so that you can provide it with a sense of closure. The thing is, if you give your anxiety and your fear of the unknown an answer, if you give yourself a reason for the uncertainty, more specifically, you give it a purpose. It will actually go away.
我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论，所以请耐心听我讲。但在我们继续之前，同样重要的是要明白，你在二十多岁时体验不确定性的方式与其他人体验这种感觉的方式并不相同。所以如果你觉得自已比其他人更难应付，你不能责备自己。90年代初的心理学家确定了他们所谓的“不确定性不容忍谱”。基本上，他们发现你在对不确定性的容忍或不容忍方面所处的位置，将决定你在做出决定之前认为自己需要多少信息。
We are going to discuss that more in a second, so just bear with me. But it's also important as well before we move on to understand that how you experience uncertainty in your 20s is not the same as how everyone else is going to experience this feeling. So you can't beat yourself up if you feel like you are struggling with it more than others. Psychologists in the early 90s, they identified what they called an intolerance for uncertainty spectrum. Basically, they found that where you sit in terms of your tolerance or intolerance for uncertainty will determine how much information you think you need before you make a decision.
他们发现这个光谱几乎是偶然的。他们实际上是在试图确定哪些人格特质会导致焦虑。在那项研究中，他们不断意识到的是，许多参与者都报告了相同的经历，即他们不一定害怕将要发生的事情，他们只是真的很想知道将要发生的事情。而正是这些人，即使他们对情节感到兴奋，也会在书中提前阅读。他们会阅读他们非常渴望观看的电影报纸上的剧透，即使他们知道这会毁掉观赏乐趣。
They discovered this spectrum, almost by accident. They were actually trying to determine what personality traits caused anxiety. And in that research, what they kept realizing was that a number of their participants all reported the same experience, this sense that they weren't necessarily scared about what was going to happen. They just really wanted to know what was going to happen. And these same people were the ones who would read ahead in books, even if they were excited by the plot line. They would read spoilers in the papers of movies that they were really eager to see, even though they knew it was going to kind of ruin the enjoyment.
当他们觉得某段关系正在消逝或感觉不对劲时，他们有时也会在关系中做出更冲动的决定，不是因为他们一定想要这段关系结束，而是对他们来说，这一点一再出现，一个已知的糟糕结果要好于一个未知的良好结果。这些人也（不出所料）更有可能被诊断出患有广泛性焦虑障碍。社会和我们世界中的大多数人在不确定性不容忍谱上都会处于中间位置。
They would also at times make more impulsive decisions in their relationships when they felt something was fading or feeling off, not because they necessarily wanted the relationship to end, but because to them, and this kept coming up over and over again, a known bad outcome was better than an unknown good outcome. These same individuals were also, surprise, surprise, more likely to have a diagnosis of generalized anxiety disorder. Most people in society and in our world will score in the middle of this spectrum for an intolerance for uncertainty.
但得分较高的人，可能就像你和我一样，往往花更多的时间在对未来的胡思乱想上，而不是活在当下。他们就是忍不住。一个对不确定性高度不容忍的人，他们可能会反复制作清单。他们在脑海中规划对话。他们在去餐馆之前很久就查看菜单，只是为了确保他们知道有他们喜欢的东西，并且知道他们要点什么。他们三次检查驾驶路线。他们做所有这些事情。基本上是为了平息这种感觉：如果我不知道，那么就会出问题。
But people who score higher, probably like you and I, tend to spend a lot more time ruminating on the future than being in the present moment. And they just can't help it. Someone with a high intolerance for uncertainty, they might make lists repeatedly. They plan out conversations in their head. They look at food menus well before they're going to a restaurant just to make sure that they know that there's something they're going to like and they know what they're going to order. They triple check driving routes. They do all these things. Basically to calm this sense that if I don't know, well, then something's going to go wrong.
我眼前的这朵云，只可能是危险的。如果这就是你，你的二十岁自然而然地（我很抱歉这么说）会感到压力更大。而且它会比那些能够自然随波逐流的人感觉更艰难，因为你不断受到未知的轰炸，这不是你的问题，而是这个十年的问题。我向你保证，我马上会给你一些好消息和解决方案，但我确实想谈谈，如果我们让不确定性迫使我们陷入角落或不采取行动的地方，会发生什么。因为不确定性是如此令人不舒服，它可能是一个非常强大的适应不良的动机，
This cloud ahead of me, it can only be dangerous. If this is you, your 20s are naturally, and I'm sorry to say it, they are going to feel a lot more stressful. And they're going to feel harder than someone who can naturally go with the flow, because you are constantly being bombarded with unknowns, and it's not you, it's this decade. I promise you I'm going to give you some good news and some solutions in just a second, but I do want to talk about what can happen if we let uncertainty force us into a corner or force us into a place of an action. Because uncertainty is so uncomfortable, it can be a very powerful maladaptive motivator,
即激励我们去做实际上违背我们利益的事情的事情。意识到这一点非常重要。这样，当我们暂停并选择是采取行动还是不采取行动时，我们可以仔细检查这是否符合我们的最大利益，或者仅仅是因为我们害怕一个并不比任何其他结果更有可能或更不可能的结果。这在我们的二十岁中表现出来的方式可能是一个很长的清单。但我会保持简短。我不想吓唬你。我只想触及让这种感觉主宰你生活两个重大后果。首先，你接受了你不配的东西，也接受了低于你能力的东西，以及低于你实际努力争取的东西。
i.e. something that motivates us to do things that are actually against our interests. And it's really important that we are aware of that. So that when we pause and are choosing whether to act, whether not to act, we can carefully examine whether this is in our best interest or just because we are scared of an outcome that is no more or less likely than any other outcome. The ways this shows up in our 20s could be a very long list. But I'm going to keep it brief. And I want to scare you. I'm just going to touch on two of the big consequences of letting this feeling rule your life. Firstly, you accept what you don't deserve and also less than what you're capable of and less than what you've actually worked for.
这就像我之前所说的，你更喜欢一个已知的糟糕结果，而不是一个未知的好的结果。这看起来可能是这样的：因为害怕找不到另一个工作而接受第一份研究生工作，即使你并不是真的很想做这份工作。接受第一个，我不知道，在Hinge上开始和你聊天的人，因为你害怕没有人会和你说话，而且你害怕在一定年龄后单身意味着什么。你选择了你看到的第一个公寓，你尝试的第一辆车。你一遍又一遍地去相同的地方，进行相同的旅行。
It's like what I said before, a known bad outcome over an unknown good outcome is what you prefer. And how that might look like is accepting the first grad offer because you're scared of not getting another even though you don't really want the job. Accepting the first person who, I don't know, starts talking to you on hinge because you're scared that no one else will talk to you and you're scared of what it will mean to be single after a certain age. You choose the first apartment you see, the first car you try out. You go to the same places, on the same trips over and over again.
因为一个不确定的结果，即使有可能是惊人的，你也不想冒这个险。请记住，我对这个没有任何评判，我自己也做过这一切，这基本上都是轶事，这基本上都是我的生活经历，因为我和你一样都在同一条船上。未能拥抱我们二十岁的不确定性的第二个后果是，我们实际上根本不采取行动。我们不选择任何工作，我们不选择任何伴侣，因为如果这不是对的呢？你知道，在第一种情况中，我们选择了第一件事，而在第二种情况中，我们什么也没选。你可能不会感到惊讶的是，完美主义和对不确定性的恐惧实际上确实是姐妹。
Because an uncertain outcome, even if there is a chance that it could be amazing, you don't want to take that risk. bear in mind I have no judgment on this I have done this myself all of that is basically anecdotal all that is basically my lived experience because I am someone who is in this in the same boat with you the second consequence of a failure to embrace uncertainty in our 20s is that we actually don't act at all we don't choose any job we don't choose any partner because what if it's not the right one You know, in the first scenario, we chose the first thing, and the scenario we don't choose anything at all. It probably won't surprise you that perfectionism and the fear of uncertainty are actually, in fact, sisters.
它们非常一致。事实上，我个人认为完美主义基本上只是换了个名字对不确定性的恐惧。它就像这种感觉的一个子流派。完美主义往往伪装成野心、高标准或对自己的巨大期望，但在内心深处它通常只是恐惧。它只是一种对未知的恐惧，对失败可能带来的恐惧，对做出错误举动的恐惧。它实际上关乎的不是把事情做到完美，而是试图消除后悔的可能性。
They are incredibly aligned. In fact, I personally think that perfectionism is basically just the fear of uncertainty with a different name. It's like a subgenre of the feeling. Perfectionism often disguises itself as ambition or high standards or great expectations for yourself, but underneath it's usually just fear. It's just a fear of the unknown, the fear of what failure might bring, the fear of making the wrong move. It is actually less about doing things perfectly and more about trying to eliminate the possibility
这就是为什么它是不确定性的近亲。它们都源于对不知道事情会如何发展的深深的不适感。在这种情况下，把完美主义看作是一种情感盔甲。如果我计划得足够多，如果我把决定推迟得足够久，如果我把一切都做得恰到好处，那么也许，也许我可以避免失望。但你真正做的只是试图跑赢不确定性。2022年的一项研究实际上观察了一群学生，以确定完美主义是否意味着人们在做决定时行动不那么迅速。
of regret. That's what makes it a close relative of uncertainty. They both come from a deep discomfort with not knowing how things will turn out. Think of perfectionism in this case as kind of like an emotional armor. If I just plan enough, if I delayed the decision long enough, if I do everything just right, then maybe, maybe I can avoid disappointment. But what you're really doing is just trying to outrun uncertainty. A 2022 study actually looked at a group of students to determine whether perfectionism meant people were less quick to act when it came to making a decision.
他们要求这些学生完成一份问卷，这本质上会根据完美主义倾向对每个学生进行排名。所以从最完美主义到最不完美主义。然后他们要求这些学生考虑一堆“你更愿意”的问题。所以你更愿意，我不知道，这个还是那个？你更愿意X还是Y？大约有，我想，50个，50种情境。他们测量了他们完成这一整套情境所需的时间。
They asked these students to complete a questionnaire, which would essentially rank each student based on perfectionist tendencies. So the most perfectionist down to the least perfectionist. And then they asked those students to consider a bunch of would you rather questions. So would you rather, I don't know, this or that? Would you rather X or Y? There was about, I think, 50 of them, 50 scenarios. And they measured how long it took them to complete these entire range of scenarios.
前25%的完美主义者完成这项练习所花费的总时间，与其余75%的学生相当。他们花了这么长时间，因为他们坐在那里考虑想要做出完美的抉择。问题是，机会并不总是等我们下定决心。重大的决定并不总是允许你拖延它们。它们会找到下一个或消失。我们二十岁很大的一部分是能够对那些感觉非常可怕的事情说“是”。是的，我要尝试。是的，我不知道会发生什么。
The top 25% of perfectionist took the same amount of time combined to complete the exercise as the remaining 75% of students. They took so much longer because they were sat there considering wanting to make the perfect choice. The thing is, opportunities don't always wait for us to make up our minds. big decisions aren't always going to let you delay them. They will find the next person or they will disappear. A big part of our 20s is being able to say yes to that thing that feels really scary. Yes, I'm going to try. Yes, I don't know what's going to happen.
排名前25%的完美主义者完成这项练习所花费的总时间，与其余75%的学生相当。他们花了这么长时间，是因为他们坐在那里纠结、想要做出完美的选择。问题是，机会并不总是等着我们去下定决心；重大的决定并不总是允许你拖延它们。它们会找到下一个目标，或者干脆消失。我们二十多岁时很重要的一点，就是能够对那些感觉非常可怕的事情说“好”。是的，我要去尝试。是的，我不知道会发生什么。
Let me just do it anyways. But when you are battling the fear of all fears, the fear of the unknown, that's going to be a lot harder for you. finally I'm here to give you some good news. This is actually something you can change. And it's something that many people have proven to themselves that they are able to overcome. So I want to explain exactly how you can do this, including something you could literally do in the next five minutes if you wanted to that will allow you to better act on your dreams, on the opportunities, on the desires of our 20s. So we're going to talk about all of that and so much more after
无论如何，我还是接着说吧。但当你正在与恐惧中的恐惧——对未知的恐惧作斗争时，这对你来说会艰难得多。最后，我是来带给你一些好消息的。这其实是你可以改变的事情。而且许多人已经向自己证明，他们能够克服这一点。所以我想要详细解释你究竟该如何做到这一点，包括一件如果你愿意的话甚至能在接下来的五分钟里亲自去做的事，它能让你更好地付诸行动去追逐梦想、把握机遇，以及我们二十多岁时的渴望。所以我们要讨论所有这些，以及更多精彩内容，在
this short break. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHartRadio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas and Las Culturistas.
这段简短的广告之后。你听过那片混乱。现在你可以亲眼看到了。我们想直接开始吗？在免费的 iHeartRadio 应用内，随时随地观看你所有喜爱的播客，从头看到尾。发出点动静吧。喔唷！在诸如 Bestie Listen、Hey Jonas 和 Las Culturistas 等节目中，捕捉每一个笑声和白眼。
Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHHRRRRRRESA. radio app search video podcasts and tap watch hey guys paul verzi here and i want to talk to you about paul's best podcast will furrows big money players network and i heart radio i sit down each week with a special guest and we discuss the absolute best of things david's it's that and then there's everything
现在有了完整视频。我就把话放这儿了。还是那些主持人和那种默契，所有那些你一直错过的爆笑时刻，现在直接呈现在你的屏幕上。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用，搜索视频播客，然后点击观看。嘿伙计们，我是保罗·韦尔齐，我想跟你们聊聊保罗的最佳播客——威爾·費瑞爾的大钱玩家网络和 iHeartRadio。我每周都会跟一位特邀嘉宾坐在一起，我们讨论绝对最棒的事情。戴维斯的那个，就是这样，然后还有一切
he would just shout one line yeah it would murder marie lunch no burr let's talk about the best moments that we had on the road i would love a goddamn do joker get last row middle scene on a Southwest Airlines flight. Joe, I was your flight. It was great. The guy on Penn State, moving on the field. And the player thought Joe is his former coach. And he hugged him.
他只会大喊一句，对，那简直能笑死人。玛丽·伦奇，没有伯尔，让我们聊聊我们在巡演中经历过的那些高光时刻。我真想要一架该死的喷气式飞机，坐在西南航空航班的最后一排中间座位。乔，那是你的航班。太棒了。宾夕法尼亚州的那个人，在球场上走动。那个球员以为乔是他的前教练。他拥抱了他。
And he hugged him. And Joe just went with it. And you know, the guy goes, what are you doing here, coach? And Joe just goes, man. And you walk in, and it is bananas. I mean, it's a feast for the eyes. And I was like, it's not my thing either. But we're here.
然后他拥抱了他。乔就顺水推舟了。你知道的，那个人说，教练，你在这里干什么？乔只是说，伙计。你走进去，里面简直乱成一团。我是说，这简直是一场视觉盛宴。我当时想，这也不是我的菜。但我们既然来了。
Went in Rome. Top athletes, chefs, musicians, everybody. Listen to Paul's best podcast on the IHeart Radio. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Maybe I have adult ADHD. I need to look this up.
入乡随俗。顶级运动员、厨师、音乐家，应有尽有。在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听保罗的最佳播客。比尔，为什么我的眼皮一直在跳？这是否意味着我处于更年期前期？也许我有成人多动症。我得查查这个。
Where's my phone? Juliana, your phone is hot to the touch. I think it's asking you for a break. You know what? Maybe I should just ask chat GPT. Or maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, like a couple sex therapist. Whoa, that escalated quickly, but okay.
我的手机呢？朱莉安娜，你的手机摸上去发烫。我想它是在要求你休息一下。你知道吗？也许我应该直接问 ChatGPT。或者我们可以去问一个真正的人。没错，比如情侣性治疗师。哇，这升级得真快，不过好吧。
Because I have questions. We have questions. And I bet everyone has questions. Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms? We do that. How about this one? Is bribing your kids bad parenting or just negotiating? Oh, and I still do need to know why was my poop green that one time?
因为我有疑问。我们有问题。我敢打赌每个人都有问题。比如，分房睡正常吗？我们就那样。那这个呢？贿赂你的孩子是糟糕的育儿方式，还是仅仅算一种谈判？哦，我还是想知道为什么我那次便便会是绿色的？
Hypothetically, right? Okay, well, instead of letting the internet guess, we've got actual people answering these exact questions. And laughing with us has got to be better than spending three hours down a rabbit hole online. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your podcast. podcast. It's Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. This season, we've got some awesome guests ready to
假设的，对吧？好吧，与其让互联网去瞎猜，不如让我们来找真人回答这些具体问题。和我们一起开怀大笑，总比在网上花三个小时深陷兔子洞要好。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《比尔与朱莉安娜播客》。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。这个季节，我们有一些超级棒的嘉宾准备
dole out advice. Guests like Tiffany Haddish. Kind of slide into people's DMs. I like Bumble. Also, girl, Farmers Only.com. At state sales, funerals, auctions are usually good. There's a lot of good men there. Grocery stores near gyms. Darcy Cardin. I remember being like, I know this is good advice, but like, I really don't want to do that. So you didn't take her advice? I didn't Are you still friends with that woman? No. She actually was kind of toxic. Neil degrass Tyson.
提供建议。像蒂凡尼·哈迪什这样的嘉宾。有点滑进人们的私信里。我喜欢 Bumble。还有，女孩，Farmers Only.com。在庭院大甩卖、葬礼、拍卖会上通常都不错。那里有很多好男人。健身房附近的杂货店。达西·卡登。我记得当时想，我知道这是个好建议，但老实说，我真的不想那样做。所以你没有听取她的建议？我没有。你还和那个女人是朋友吗？不。她其实有点毒。尼尔·德rasse·泰森。
I spent my whole life looking up. I was a geek kid. I had a telescope at age 12. So you didn't have sex for a long time? Sherry O'Terry. Were you a soap opera person? Young and restless. Okay.
我花了一生时间仰望星空。我曾是个极客小孩。我 12 岁时就有一个望远镜。所以你很长时间没有性生活？谢丽·奥特里。你是个肥皂剧迷吗？《年轻的骚动》。好吧。
Well, first of all, you should know it's the young and the restless. I can't even believe you're mispronouncing the title. Some of us abbreviated because we've been so many years. T.S. Madison. Are you into Polly? No. Oh, no, I don't think so. No, I could have told you no on that.
嗯，首先，你应该知道它是《年轻的骚动》。我简直不敢相信你把剧名都读错了。我们中的一些人把它简写了，因为我们看了很多年。T.S.麦迪逊。你喜欢多边恋吗？不。哦，不，我不这么认为。不，我本来就能对那个说不。
Girl, why do you not? It's a polly. Just based on what she's wearing and the way her hair is styled. She was not in a polly. Good, try polly. Anna Ferris, Dave Franco, Madeline Kline, Hannah Gadsby, Adam Scott, Wanda Sykes, and more. Listen to Dear Chelsea on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2015, Teenager Join More,
天哪，你怎么会不这样？这是一个波莉。仅凭她的穿着和发型，她就不是一个波莉。好，试试波莉。安娜·法瑞丝、戴夫·弗兰科、玛德琳·克莱因、汉娜·加兹比、亚当·斯科特、旺达·赛克斯等等。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“亲爱的切尔西”。2015年，青少年乔恩·莫尔，
Morgan discovered strangely compelling YouTube sermons from the religious group Israel United in Christ, or IUIC. Her initial curiosity developed into devotion. She distanced herself from friends and family, embraced new identity, immersed herself in the IUIC, and believed she'd found the truth. IUIC is the best family that I've ever had. In fact, she had found what many called a cult. And on Boxing Day 2018, Joy disappeared forever.
摩根在YouTube上发现了来自宗教团体“以色列统一在基督里”（简称IUIC）的诡异且引人入胜的布道。她最初的好奇心逐渐演变成了一种痴迷。她疏远了朋友和家人，接受了新的身份，全身心投入到IUIC中，并相信自己找到了真理。“IUIC是我见过的最好的家庭。”事实上，她找到了许多人所说的邪教。在2018年的节礼日，乔伊永远地消失了。
In the new six-part investigative podcast, The Missing Sister, Charlie Brinkhurst Cuff and Freiturn, explore Joy Story, the family she left, and the religious group she found. You know when you get out of freedom, I don't want to be here. I want to get out. I want to go ahead and out. It's a story about truth, lies, a young woman yearning to belong, and a family still waiting for answers.
在这部全新的六集调查播客《失踪的姐姐》中，查理·布林克赫斯特-库夫和弗赖图恩探讨了乔伊的故事、她离开的家庭以及她发现的宗教团体。“你知道当你获得自由时，我不想留在这里。我想离开。我想继续前行并走出去。”这是一个关于真理、谎言、一个渴望归属感的年轻女性以及一个仍在等待答案的家庭的故事。
All episodes available now to binge. Listen to The Missing Sister on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so we are back talking about uncertainty in our 20s. And luckily for us, we are actually not the first generation to feel this way, nor will we be the last. And that's good news because it means that there are a lot of people who have come up with some really amazing approaches to this feeling
所有剧集现已全部上线，可一口气听完。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《失踪的姐姐》。好了，我们回到正题，来谈谈我们二十多岁时的不确定性。幸运的是，我们其实并不是第一代有这种感觉的人，也不会是最后一代。这是个好消息，因为这意味着有很多人已经想出了一些非常棒的方法来应对这种感觉，
that helped get them through this period of discomfort, which will hopefully help you as well. The biggest thing we can do for our uncertainty in our 20s, and I've been hinting at this for the entire episode, is to basically assign it a purpose, because that satisfies our deeper desire for a reason, a meeting, and kind of just a sense of why. Why is this happening?
这些方法帮助他们度过了这段不适期，希望也能对你有所帮助。我们在二十多岁时面对不确定性能做的最重要的事情——我整个节目都在暗示这一点——基本上就是给它赋予一个目的，因为这满足了我们内心深处对原因、意义以及一种“为什么”的渴望。为什么会发生这种事？
The purpose you assign to your uncertainty, it could be that you see this as a learning opportunity. It could be that you view uncertainty as a rite of passage. It could be that uncertainty is a sign that you're opening yourself, up to new things, which are scary. It could be a call to surrender and just to accept life as it is. It could be a real spiritual thing. It could be that uncertainty just makes for a really good story.
你赋予不确定性的目的，可以是把这看作一个学习的机会。你可以将不确定性视为一种成人礼。不确定性可能是一个信号，表明你正在向新事物敞开心扉，而这些新事物是令人害怕的。这可能是一种臣服的呼唤，去接受生活的本原。这可能是一件真正具有精神意义的事。也可能不确定性只是为了成就一个真正精彩的故事。
And you value a good story and you can't have one without uncertainty. Whatever it is, whatever makes uncertainty feel meaningful to you, hone in on that. Anytime you feel overwhelmed by the feeling, remind yourself, okay, but this has a purpose. This has a meaning. For me, I personally think of uncertainty as a sign that I'm about to really grow as a person and for lack of a better word, I'm about to level up. Every time I have ever felt scared, lost, uncertain, it has always been the beginning of something just over the horizon that I haven't been able to see yet. Like, it always signals to me that like something really big is about to come. That way now, now that I know that's its purpose, I actually almost get excited
而你珍视一个好故事，没有不确定性就无法拥有它。无论它是什么，无论是什么让不确定性对你而言变得有意义，都要专注于这一点。每当你被这种感觉压倒时，提醒自己：好吧，但这有一个目的。这有一个意义。就我个人而言，我把不确定性看作是一个信号，表明我即将作为一个人真正成长，换个词说，我即将“升级”。每当我感到害怕、迷茫、不确定时，它总是地平线上某种我尚未看清的事物的开始。它总是向我发出信号，表明某种非常重大的事情即将到来。这样一来，既然我知道了它的目的，我几乎就会开始兴奋，
when I'm feeling that way. I feel like I get kind of giddy. I'm like ready to be surprised. And I really feel like I'm in preparation mode for whatever is about to happen next. The reason this works is because when we assign a role to our uncertainty, this actually gives us a cognitive framework through which we can accept it, through which we can just let it exist and actually focus on what we need to focus on. We give the annoying voice a job. It's like when a toddler, I don't know if you've been around kids a lot, but when like a toddler or a child is being really annoying,
当我产生这种感觉的时候。我觉得自己有点飘飘然，好像随时准备好迎接惊喜。我真的觉得自己进入了备战状态，迎接接下来要发生的事情。这种方法之所以奏效，是因为当我们为不确定性赋予一个角色时，这实际上为我们提供了一个认知框架，通过它我们可以接受它，通过它我们可以让它存在，并真正专注于我们需要关注的事情。我们给这个烦人的声音安排了一项工作。就像当一个蹒跚学步的孩子——我不知道你是否经常跟小孩子接触，但当一个蹒跚学步的孩子或小孩子非常烦人时，
so you tell them they have to rearrange all the pens or they have to divide up all their dolls or pick up something like rice, I don't know, you give them a job so you can get to work. You give the annoying voice somewhere, someone else to talk to or something else to do. The second way to really confront your uncertainty is also to look for stories of people who didn't have it all figured out or whom dealt with supreme uncertainty and came out the other side rather than just looking for people who seem like a natural A to B success story. The natural success stories are all we seem to see these days. So you would think that most people who you admire have never struggled the way that you do and that you have. That's false. It's a huge lie. It's a big myth.
于是你告诉他们必须重新排列所有的笔，或者必须把他们所有的洋娃娃分开，或者捡起像米粒一样的东西，我不知道，你给他们找个活干，这样你就能开始工作了。你给这个烦人的声音安排了别的地方、别的人去倾诉，或者别的事情去做。直面不确定性的第二个方法，也是去寻找那些并不是一切都顺风顺水的人的故事，或者那些经历过极度不确定性最终苦尽甘来的故事，而不是只去寻找那些看起来像是天生从A到B走向成功的故事。如今我们似乎只能看到那些天生成功的故事。所以你可能会认为，你钦佩的大多数人从来没有像你现在或曾经那样挣扎过。这是假的。这是一个弥天大谎。这是一个巨大的神话。
When you start collecting these stories, you will find that almost every single person who has made something of themselves has an uncertainty story. Dochi, for example, that's one I've recently added to my list, The Woman of the Hour. She posted a YouTube video back in 2020, only like five years ago about how she got fired from her job. And in it she's like, tomorrow I'm just going to door knock at a bunch of studios and just see if they will give me an internship.
当你开始收集这些故事时，你会发现几乎每一个有所成就的人都有一个关于不确定性的故事。比如多琪（Doja Cat），这是我最近加入我的名单的人，“当红炸子鸡”。她在2020年发布了一个YouTube视频，大约也就是五年前，讲的是她是如何被工作炒鱿鱼的。在视频里她说，明天我要去一家又一家工作室敲门，看看他们愿不愿意给我一个实习机会。
She just won a Grammy. Five years ago, she was completely unsure of where she was going to end up. And she ended up in the right place because she lent into it. The founder of Spanx, she's another one on my list. She used to sell fax machines like door-to-door.
她刚刚赢得了一座格莱美奖。五年前，她完全不确定自己最终会走向何方。她最终到达了正确的地方，因为她顺应了它。Spanx的创始人，她是我的名单上的另一个人。她以前挨家挨户推销传真机。
Now she runs a billion-dollar industry. Stephen King, he's another one. His draft for his book, Carrie, which is now a cult classic, a favorite of so many, he literally threw that manuscript in the trash after it was rejected 30 times. And that book is a cultural icon. I even think of my mom, like my mom is the one that often comes to mind for me. You know, she was kicked out of university because she got such poorly bad grades. They basically expelled her. And then she took a year off to travel. She didn't really know what she wanted to do.
现在她经营着一个价值数十亿美元的产业。斯蒂芬·金，他是另一个例子。他的书《魔女嘉莉》的初稿——现在这是一部邪典经典，是许多人的最爱——在被拒绝了30次后，他 literalmente（字面意思上）把那份手稿扔进了垃圾桶。而那本书现在是一个文化标志。我甚至会想到我的妈妈，我的妈妈经常是我脑海中最先浮现的人。你知道，她因为成绩太差而被大学开除。他们基本上把她除名了。然后她请假一年去旅游。她其实不知道自己想做什么。
She came back. She did something different. And she graduated with the top job. And now she's like this incredibly powerful, successful girl boss. All these people and you have something very important in common. In their journey to success and to wherever they ended up, there were moments when they had absolutely no idea what was next. And they just had to bet on themselves.
她回来了。她做了一些不同的事情。她以优异的成绩毕业。现在她是一个极其强大、成功的职场女强人。所有这些人，还有你，都有一个非常共同点。在他们通往成功和最终归宿的旅程中，曾有过无数个时刻，他们完全不知道接下来会发生什么。他们只能把赌注押在自己身上。
And they just had to trust. that they were capable. And once you start searching for these stories, you will see them everywhere. You will see them constantly until one day you'll have your own version of this story, your own version of how you overcame uncertainty, how in hindsight the path was actually so clear the entire time. Another small thing you can do, and it's going to sound so minuscule and silly, you might be tempted to skip it. Please don't. I want you to make a little bit. I want you to make a little bit of, a playlist that you feel represents yourself and play it whenever you feel uncomfortable or confused as a way to really just bring yourself back and center yourself. Even if it doesn't
他们只能去相信自己有能力。一旦你开始寻找这些故事，你就会到处看到它们。你会不断地看到它们，直到有一天，你也会拥有属于你自己的这个故事版本，拥有属于你自己的版本，讲述你是如何克服不确定性的，讲述事后回想起来这条道路其实是如何一目了然的。你可以做的另一个小事——这听起来可能微不足道且有些傻，你可能会想跳过它。请不要这样。我希望你制作一点……我希望你制作一点播放列表，让你觉得能代表你自己，每当你感到不舒服或困惑时就播放它，以此来真正让自己平静下来并找回中心。即使它不
necessarily help you feel less uncertain, it can just help you with the general feelings of discomfort and strangeness that you may be having. And just is like a fun thing to do, a fun thing to do to remind yourself of who you are, of who you want to be, of what your core values are all through music. These songs reflect how you see yourself back at you. And that is a very special, familiar, beautiful feeling. There's actually this brilliant 2014 paper from a researcher in Texas that talks about how music contributes to the formation of our identity
一定能帮你减少不确定感，它也只 能帮你缓解你可能正在经历的不适感和陌生感的整体情绪。这只是一件有趣的事，一件做起来很有趣的事，通过音乐提醒你自己是谁、你想成为什么样的人、你的核心价值观是什么。这些歌曲将你眼中的自己反射给你。那是一种非常特别、熟悉、美好的感觉。德克萨斯州的一位研究人员在2014年其实有一篇非常精彩的论文，谈到音乐是如何促进我们的身份认同的形成，
and can help us trust ourselves more because it acts as a touchstone when we feel challenged. It represents all the times we have previously overcome challenge. challenges, all the times we previously experienced joy. And the music we choose really does reflect our values and says something about how we see ourselves. And so when you're kind of externally lost and don't really know who you are and can't really find your way back, music is just like beautiful anchor. You know, I have a playlist like this. The playlist is called If Gemma was a playlist. And I was listening to it literally the other day and it has songs from
并且能够帮助我们更加信任自己，因为它在我们受到挑战时充当了一种试金石。它代表了我们过去克服挑战的所有时刻，以及我们过去体验过快乐的所有时刻。我们选择的音乐确实反映了我们的价值观，并说明了我们如何看待自己。因此，当你内心感到迷失、不太清楚自己是谁、无法真正找到回家的路时，音乐就像是一个美丽的锚。你知道，我有一个这样的播放列表。这个播放列表叫做“如果杰玛是一个播放列表”。我前几天还在听它，里面有从
2016 all the way up to last week. And it's really a beautiful way to see how I've transformed to be able to categorically see different chapters in my life and what was happening during them, like, and the music brings back all those memories and also just to see how far I've come. And so it's something you can literally take five minutes, do for yourself right now. It's a fun exercise. I promise you, it will help you ground yourself during this like crazy chaotic period. On a much larger scale, the biggest antidote for uncertainty is really just this. Just try something. Try anything.
2016年一直到上周的歌曲。这真的是一种美好的方式，让我看到自己是如何蜕变的，能够明确地看到我生活中的不同章节以及期间发生了什么，比如，音乐带回了所有的回忆，也让我看到了自己已经走得有多远。所以这可以说是你可以花上整整五分钟，现在就为自己做的一件事。这是一个有趣的练习。我向你保证，它会帮助你在这样一段疯狂混乱的时期里脚踏实地。从更大的层面上来说，对抗不确定性的最大解药其实就是这个：去尝试一些东西。尝试任何东西。
Choose something that interests you to get good at. And when that thing stops serving you, choose something else. We have to let go of this idea that every decision you make in life has to naturally flow into the next and the next and the next and that you have to you have to have some step-by-step plan that you can follow for your life. Your life is not a recipe. You're not making a cake. You're not cooking sour. It's a series of experiments that take you to different places that you didn't even know you were going to get to.
选择一件你感兴趣的事情并把它做好。当那件事不再适合你时，选择另一件。我们必须放下这种想法，即你在生活中做出的每一个决定都必须自然而然地衔接下一个、再下一个、再下一个，并且你必须为你的人生制定某种可以遵循的逐步计划。你的人生不是食谱。你不是在做蛋糕。你不是在做酸橘汁腌鱼。它是一系列把你带到你甚至不知道自己会到达的陌生地方的实验。
And when you give yourself permission to just try, you really break this cycle of needing to know. You break the cycle of needing to have all the answers. And you move as well from that rumination spiral of, am I doing the right thing? Is this the best choice to just knowing that if you're taking action and if you're doing something, you are making the right choice. Even in perfect action, even the wrong choice is still a better choice than not doing anything at all. And it also gives you data.
当你允许自己去尝试时，你真的打破了这种“必须知道”的循环。你打破了那种需要拥有所有答案的循环。你也将自己从那种反刍式的内耗中解放出来，不再去想“我做的事对吗？这是最好的选择吗？”，而是确信只要你在采取行动，只要你在做些什么，你就是在做正确的选择。即使是不完美的行动，即使是错误的的选择，也比什么都不做要好。它还能为你提供数据。
It gives you experience. It gives you stories. A question to really ask yourself as well if you're kind of thinking, okay, that's great, but which direction should I choose, especially if you're someone who. who has a lot of hobbies and interests and passions and ambitions. The question to ask yourself is just, what would make me most disappointed if I didn't do this? What would I be most regretful around not doing in 20 years' time?
它能为你提供经验。它能为你提供故事。如果你在想“好吧，这很好，但我应该选择哪个方向？”，特别是如果你是一个有很多爱好、兴趣、热情和雄心壮志的人，那么真正需要问自己的一个问题其实是：如果我不这样做，什么会让我感到最失望？20年过去后，对于没有做这件事，我会产生最大的遗憾是什么？
This mentally makes you kind of compute how much you have to lose by not acting rather than getting you stuck in this spiral of how much you have to lose by acting. It reminds me of this quote, you could take a million detours to your destination and still get there faster than someone who never got in the car. And that's the idea I really want to leave you with today. Uncertainty in our 20s is inevitable, but it's actually a really profound sign that you're expanding and you are growing and you are reaching new spaces you haven't yet experienced. That's a good thing. I congratulations. If you're feeling uncertain, that is such a beautiful.
这种心理会让你去计算如果不行动你会失去多少，而不是让你陷入“行动了会失去多少”的内耗循环中。这让我想起了一句名言：你可能会为了到达目的地而绕无数个弯路，但还是能比那些从未上车的人更快到达。这就是我今天真正想留给你的观点。我们二十多岁时的不确定性是不可避免的，但它实际上是一个非常深刻的信号，表明你正在扩张，你正在成长，你正在触及你尚未体验过的新空间。这是件好事。恭喜你。如果你感到不确定，那真是太美妙了。
sign and I wish I could give you all the applause for just trying and pushing yourself into new places and spaces. I know it feels uncomfortable, but I promise you that this discomfort has a purpose that you cannot yet see, lean into it, assign it a purpose while you're waiting and just act, do anything, even if it's small things. I think that that's a great solution for avoiding a worse discomfort of looking back your life and realizing that you never did anything because you were scared of the unknown when the unknown is something that we always have to exist side by side with. And the only way to escape the unknown is to create a known, is to create a reality that you do really enjoy and that works for you. And the other way you can do that is through action. So that's a rather
这是一个信号，我真希望我能为你所有的尝试和将自己推向新地点、新空间的勇气致以热烈的掌声。我知道这让人感觉不舒服，但我向你保证，这种不适感有一个你现在还看不到的目的，去顺应它，在等待的同时为它赋予目的，然后去行动，去做任何事，哪怕是很小的事。我认为这是一个极好的解决方案，可以避免那种更糟糕的不适感——那就是回首自己的一生，意识到自己因为害怕未知而什么都没做，而未知是我们永远必须与之并存的东西。逃避未知的唯一方法就是创造一个已知，创造一个你真正喜欢并且适合你的现实。而你能做到这一点的另一种方式就是通过行动。所以这是一个相当
simple message, but also deeply complex message if you think about it to end the episode with. I just hope that it brings you a sense of comfort that you're not the only one going through it. totally know it's going to work out for you. It's totally going to work out for you. I know that. I can give you that promise right now. So thank you so much for listening. If you have made it this far, let's leave a little emoji in the comments below that represents how you're feeling about your life, how uncertainty feels in your body right now. Just so I know if you've made it this far, if you're one of the loyal listeners, make sure that you are following along or subscribed wherever you are listening on YouTube, on Spotify, Apple, whatever one,
简单的信息，但如果你仔细想想，也是一个极其复杂的信息，本集节目就以此结尾。我只是希望这能给你带来一种安慰，让你知道并不是只有你一个人在经历这一切。完全相信这一切对你来说都会迎刃而解的。这一切绝对会对你迎刃而解的。我知道这一点。我现在就可以向你做出这个承诺。非常感谢你的收听。如果你听到了这里，让我们在下方的评论区留下一个微小的表情符号，代表你对生活的感受，代表你此刻身体对不确定性的感受。让我知道你是否听到了这里，如果你是忠实听众之一，请确保你在你收听的任何地方——YouTube、Spotify、Apple等任何平台上——都点击了关注或订阅，
and give us a five-star review. If you feel called to do so, it really does help the show grow and reach new audiences, a new, fantastic, wonderful, 20-somethings and older. Also, make sure you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to be part of future episodes, if you want to DM me, episode suggestions, if you have questions, dilemmas, you may even be able to be featured in an episode just like this one. So follow me over there.
并给我们一个五星好评。如果你觉得有必要这样做，这确实有助于节目的成长并接触到新的受众，那些崭新的、梦幻般的、二十多岁及以上的年轻人们。另外，请确保在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想参与未来的节目，如果你想给我发私信、提供节目建议、如果你有疑问、困惑，你甚至可能会出现在像这样的一集节目中。所以去那边关注我吧。
And until next time, Stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, especially in the face of uncertainty. We will talk very, very soon. Why do some women yearn for Shakira's black hair to make a comeback? And whatever happened to the power couple of my dreams, Mariah Carey and Luis Miguel, I'm Maria Garcia. You may remember me from my podcast, Anything for Selena, or My Divo. And now I'm back to unpack more stories from the present and the past.
直到下一次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己好一点，尤其是在面对不确定性的时候。我们很快很快就会再聊。为什么有些女性渴望夏奇拉的黑发卷土重来？我梦想中的权力情侣玛丽亚·凯莉和路易斯·米格尔到底怎么了？我是玛丽亚·加西亚。你可能从我的播客《为赛琳娜做任何事》或《我的天后》中还记得我。现在我回来了，要从现在和过去中解包更多故事。
Listen to Mui Excited with Maria Garcia on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Where's my phone? Juliana, maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, because I have questions, and I bet you do too. Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms? We do that, and I still need to know why my poop's been green.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听玛丽亚·加西亚主持的《Mui Excited》。比尔，为什么我的眼皮在跳？这是否意味着我处于围绝经期？我的手机呢？朱莉安娜，也许我们可以问问真人。是的，因为我有疑问，我打赌你也有。比如，分房睡正常吗？我们就是这样的，我仍然需要知道为什么我的便便是绿色的。
We've got actual people answering these exact questions. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your podcast. I'm Munga Chitigula, and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, curmudgins, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us.
我们有真人来回答这些具体的问题。收听《比尔与朱莉安娜》播客。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您收听播客的任何地方。我是蒙加·奇蒂古拉，我的播客《天际线大道》新一季回归了。这一次，我采访了科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的人、蓝调音乐拥有者、超级老年人和果阿顶级的冷冻疗法实验室，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷以及这对我们所有人的意义。
And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive How to Live Forever on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Betrayal Weekly is back with brand new stories from threatening text messages disturbing a small Midwestern town.
在这个过程中我也遇到了一些麻烦。我想大概开始“骨骼塑形”吧。这没用。让它看起来更立体。他们说这管用。我不知道。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》。《每周背叛》携全新故事回归，从小镇中令人不安的威胁短信开始。
It was from an unknown number. Who else is getting these messages? Why did it start with us? To long cons and stolen identities. Who lies about being this sick? This was the last time I ever believed a word she said. Listen to Betrayal Weekly on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard.
那是来自一个未知号码。还有谁在收到这些消息？为什么是从我们开始的？到漫长骗局和被盗身份。谁会谎称自己生病得这么重？这是我最后一次相信她说的任何一个字。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《每周背叛》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《I Am Rapaport立体声播客》与你听过的任何人都不一样。
If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid, Jafar Jackson, should absolutely positively get nominated for his. This portrayal is Michael Jackson. Listen to IMRAP report on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你正在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及其他任何吸引我注意的事情的强烈见解，那就赶快订阅吧。这个名叫贾法尔·杰克逊的孩子，绝对应该因为他饰演迈克尔·杰克逊的表现而获得提名。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 IMRAP 报告。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。